ce n'est pas une illusion d'optique à
bord coûte à de nombreux édifices sont
déformés a fait ces fissures et les
rousses qui bouge circuler en auto dans
cette région a de quoi donner le mal de
mer vorkouta été construite sur le
pergélisol les premiers édifices date
des années 30 quand on ne parlait pas de
réchauffement planétaire
quand le sol était gelé en profondeur
toute l'année maintenant ça craque de
partout
olga chain a décidé de placer tous ses
vêtements dans des sacs pour être prêt à
partir à tout moment
elle a peur que son appartement
s'écroule sur elle elle a déjà eu toute
une fausse et est un tricheur
pousse-t-il eau potable
un jour mon plafond s'est mis à bouger
et descendre de 10 cm
j'ai pris mes papiers mon argent j'ai
réveillé ma fille et nous sommes partis
en courant c'était comme si quelqu'un
déchirait la maison en mots tu as des
survivants les déchirures sont bien
visibles chez elle elle a beau
calfeutrait cimenté tous ses frites y
est un parent ou d'un boulet mailhiot
c'est pire s'il était chaud attention ça
bouge encore plus de vignes et de gris
la porte ne ferme plus une catastrophe
selon le jo
elle attend que la ville lui trouve un
nouvel appartement
certains édifices s'effondre d'autres
sont ceinturés de corse et en métal pour
éviter les fissures
près des piliers enfoncé dans le
pergélisol on voit deux drôles
d'installation comme des antennes et
doit petra 20 ingénieurs en construction
nous explique que ces objets étranges
sont des termes aux stabilisateurs
ils agissent comme des réfrigérateurs et
ils font en sorte que le sol reste gelé
autour des piliers pour éviter que
l'édifice bouge dit ibra les trois ans
passe pour longtemps cette maison ici a
été construite quand on ne pensait pas
au père gély sol on ne savait pas que ça
pouvait prendre un jour c'est lui qui a
effectué les travaux ici au coût de 100
mille dollars
la ville préfère préserver ce qu'on peut
sauver
vous savez pour construire un édifice
comme ça dans le nord ça coûte très cher
pendant des décennies ces dix là était à
des goulags où le régime communiste a
envoyé les dissidents les opposants au
régime
il y en a eu des dizaines de milliers à
bord coûta vivent dans des conditions
abjectes
par endroits on a l'impression que la
nature temps d'effacer ce terreau est de
passer de voir coûta ici c'était
difficile par exemple c'est un théâtre
où on emmenait des prisonniers du goulag
des acteurs des danseurs des musiciens
pour présenter des spectacles pour
amuser distraire la population locale
mais au delà des dégâts bien visible
plusieurs études scientifiques prévoient
une catastrophe si le pergélisol
continue de fondre on note ces dizaines
de gigantesque cratère observée ces
dernières années en sibérie qui serait
dû à l'explosion de méthane créé par la
libération de tonnes de bactéries
emprisonné dans la glace depuis des
millénaires
plus on libère du méthane plus on
accélère le changement climatique
une récente étude américaine en alaska
concluez que le pergélisol fond à une
vitesse incroyable
mais ça ne convainc pas tout le monde
tout être humain l'a dit mirko cléac'h
of glaciologue ne crois pas que le
réchauffement planétaire soit causé par
l'activité humaine
encore moins qu'il va durer neuf chez
eux
je ne sais pas si c'est pour le meilleur
ou pour le pire mais je pense que
l'humanité ne peut rien faire pour
changer ce processus plus road on the
run la nature a ses propres lois et une
des lois principal c'est celle des
siècles à tout prix il croit que le
cycle de réchauffement est terminé et
qu'on va assister à un refroidissement
l'a dit mercredi à cove fait partie des
nombreux scientifiques qui avait
recommandé au président poutine de ne
pas ratifier le protocole de kyoto qui
selon eux n'avaient aucune base
scientifique
le président poutine m'a d'ailleurs à
quelques reprises mis en doute
l'influencent humaine dans le changement
climatique
dans la région de volta en tout cas on
sent bien le réchauffement
les gens voient depuis cinq ans un
phénomène qu'ils n'avaient jamais
observé
il pousse des arbres dans la toundra ici
raymond st-pierre radio canada avoir
coûteux